okay let's now go back to the delay of
the election
idea that was floated months ago joe
biden said that
he believed donald trump was going to
try to create some kind of emergency as
a pretext to delay the election
and a whole bunch of people said oh joe
biden's crazy
trump's not going to do that and then
last week donald trump floated the idea
on twitter
of delaying the election and has since
insisted at every opportunity that this
is going to be a rigged
phony election a top democratic
congressman in the house
now specifically says that donald trump
is going to use emergency powers to
remain in the white house if he loses
the election
so this idea is not about delaying the
election
it's about declaring an emergency if he
loses
to not vacate the white house now i'm
talking here about house majority whip
congressman james clyburn this is
probably the strongest reaction from an
actual
federal lawmaker so far saying trump's
idea is to put a cloud over the election
and then use some kind of an emergency
to justify staying in the oval office
here is congressman clyburn himself on
cnn sunday
do you really think donald trump is
comparable to adolf hitler
what i said started about two and a half
maybe three years ago after one of his
state of the unions
that i feel very strongly that this
man has taken on a strong-armed tactics
and i feel very strongly that she
is mussolini who is hitler
i said that back then and i believe that
i believe very strongly
this guy never had any idea
about being one to peacefully
transfer power i don't think he plans to
leave
at the white house he doesn't plan to
have fed and unfettered
elections i believe that he
plans to install himself in some kind of
emergency way
to continue to hold on to office and
that's why the american people
had better wake up now you know there
are people who are not particularly
pleased with clyburn especially because
he's mentioning
you know mussolini and hitler in the
same breath as trump
for me what's lacking is a more detailed
explanation about how
exactly trump plans to do it and so
absent a specific plan
i still don't see this as something that
donald trump could actually get away
with but
understand that this is a different idea
than delaying the election delaying the
election is what trump floated last week
the idea here is trump loses but then
uses some kind of emergency declaration
to try to stay in power so a few
different things number one
even republicans are saying all of these
ideas are bogus marco rubio saying
you know trump can suggest delaying the
election but that's not what's going to
happen
i think that there's actually a point
where the the idea of of debating this
is arguably the problem and let me
explain to you what i mean
when you bring on experts politicians
whoever
to argue about can trump delay the
election
could he use an emergency to stay in
power or whatever
you are legitimizing the idea of this as
a concept and what i mean by that is
the real newsworthiness of this story
is the wildly authoritarian completely
unhinged idea of delaying the election
that's what needs to be reported on
when you bring in a member of congress
or a legal expert and say could trump do
this or
how could trump do this or is trump
doing this justified
you are creating the notion that there's
something to debate here
i do a bit of a different type of show
than what you see on corporate media so
i've pointed out
trump can't really do this states run
their own elections you need
at the federal level some kind of decree
from the house and senate which you're
not going to get
but the focus of this story needs to be
on corporate media that donald trump is
alluding to something completely
authoritarian and dictatorial it is the
idea
of something that despots do and
normalizing this idea of a delay or
staying in power
is almost saying it could be justified
if there is a debate as to whether trump
would have the legal authority to do
this
it validates what should be a completely
immediately dismissed authoritarian idea
that's my concern about some of these
types of segments
so i'm curious to hear from you about
that let me know what you think